ten ran baby oh my so sexy now jiggle
that bad baby for me oh my god Becky oh
yeah blood hey there's a custom right
here yeah welcome to slender tabbies oh
god there's other people like a server
yeah mid boring Mason oh now they're all
here at me like yeah that's my [ __ ] hey
stop stop make me fly okay my [ __ ]
don't go near my [ __ ] No - break break
it up boy we need to fight oh oh hey
let's go without them we don't use them
yeah yeah already got a custard right so
we should be getting chased by stuff
yeah okay let's make sure they die and
we live yeah yeah yeah okay oh god what
the [ __ ] is that what that was like good
yeah what the [ __ ] wait you get a fake
film it Jimmy I'm filming it I'm gonna
yeah filming it help thank us peace we
come in peace hey stop China I think
he's Ethiopian ha he's speaking the
language uh where'd everybody go
I died because he told me to film em
really ha ha ha
as soon as you said it I film them and
then I die Daigo come here there's an 18
plus room movie shouldn't they
you think there's really 18 year-olds in
there yeah yeah me too actually
awareness all right yeah that's see you
see I couldn't even find me that's how
boring name it was chant Angus hey we're
in this map again huge Emile G leat fig
you like my name bruh
yeah bruh I like your name I like you I
pray oh my god where'd you get that hat
it's a girl said real cow my god looks
so good
Jilly I'm really jelly alright I'm
taking a custard [ __ ] you your custard
1400 the hell are we gonna do that you
can do it oh wait there's actually one
here okay okay thirteen it'd be great if
you helped out can't no way a fly
through there where are you I'm in your
back so this is what you're supposed to
be like like a dead weight yeah des vins
that's what I was looking forward before
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it makes
Ethiopian noises when it comes after you
like it clicks what the [ __ ] is that
Ethiopia noise hey there it is you feel
oh god I hope it's is he hoping you
better go in he got a good way to
Ethiopia guys crazy and the comment
section but having EPA doesn't sit with
your foot nice you can attend either
before it's a shut up but havin
Ethiopian why you make fun of it Bo Peep
yeah damn it I can't seem get a normal
name easy Oh some custard that's why
they're after it's cuz Ethiopian people
are always hungry cuz it's looking they
owe another custard they [ __ ] another
custard oh I found a custard - bruh
yeah bruh yeah oh yeah oh god he's askin
easy though he's after me Oh feel me I'm
tanking him oh no what the [ __ ] I'm
tanking the Ethiopians cool you're
tackling him you can't tank an EP you
just follow me round in circles how the
[ __ ] do you say come back I find a
custard
no way you're gonna make it more mad
you're running on these circles is that
what you're doing this is the scariest
game ever played I'm freaking out right
now I can't even see it
oh there you go well he is making ideo
pins night it's a dead space guy with
the slender tubby face is that it yeah
I'm scary
that's pretty high these sick moves to
get these sick moves oh damn girl yeah
what 360 whoop way to go
where is he
guys after me now oh good now for the
camera oh yeah work it like a Paris
Hilton how do you get on team so good
you're like out Paris Hilton eight yeah
just a person can't be the person tester
okay so I guess we can find some
custards because he's not doing evening
um I'm looking for him pitchers stop it
I don't get any pictures I'm offended
are you fine I feel like an AVO peon I
job Angie okay lucky I flew on you thank
you
yay are we actually gonna bother finding
on I don't know
just going I'm like whatever it doesn't
really matter it's too exciting I mean
how can we stop well we could film each
other's bikes gonna fill my butt
well yeah me we can die together Romeo
oh no I'm not gonna let that Ethiopian
guy touch yes
okay those that lost my custard day it
I'm really looking for them Anna I don't
know I guess we need to go to the middle
the separate on the outside yeah I don't
know how to get in the middle there hey
if you find all the custard whoa one
more custard left Oh Wayne that spooky
face my god oh my god I've peed my Benz
this sorry can we have to stop at a
change pit Oh make it you claim that's
the face I saw hey hey he's like all you
found all the custard yeah I might have
any custard hmm oh all right what was it
called room 18 plus 8 3 5 thank you plus
you want to go there don't you
yeah I mean I want to talk to only 18
year olds minecraft we're here finally
this is pretty good now I can actually
see this is fantastic we can jump on
each other all day way best game ever
ten out of ten
IGN what ten out of ten yeah I can't I
can't knock this tree down whoo oh dude
there's one here he's just standing
there
haha shut up haha really man of God
this is not an eto pian give me the ID
open guys thank you sketch it way better
all right
is easy to find the constant they killed
me now and Peter Pan knew yesterday yeah
you did I fell through the ground
alright let's see that again that didn't
really go well where are you alright
let's go what are you an angel I don't
hear the other one you're fake mains
okay here you go that way
alright I'm getting this me okay what
ABT toast cane I bet they're high me no
oh there he is super far away no you
don't he's going for custard lady die
piggy die for the damn custard you won't
shut up how can you get up here no we
can't get up here mister can you see me
at all
I fell through the floor I couldn't see
dirt ah [ __ ] cuz I'm like climbing in
the trees and [ __ ] it's pretty bad eyes
well you can join the game again oh no I
fell down ah yes I'm not so energy yeah
dig it
are you consuming on the camera whoa
whoa Ken give me a bite hey go are you
mmm thumbnail right there that's gonna
get all o everybody's click on that that
tele ass at Le ass texture alright I see
something far up there oh there's a cave
oh let's check out the king or if he's
he's in there vaping or something what
else would he be doing I could only hope
he's happy
oh yeah what else do you do it again Ken
now this brown is here alright so
there's this thing that you can not
click on there's some it looks clickable
and there's a bed on fire
mmm with no animation that's from all
the all the friction of the sheets
yeah I know exactly with the shock of it
here my mouth hey custard you found it
I did find it I went into the lava tube
but nothing happened so don't worry
whatever all the Sammy's like oh Jesus
don't sneak up on me like that kid
I thought you thought about the Sammy's
hands look at this [ __ ] tree in the
mountain best rehab I think they grew
that tree in there yeah oh no I'm I'm
really amazed by it actually it's be
good
I removed that tree in the first game
that would teleport you when you step
down oh yeah
and no it wouldn't telephone you would
just launch you really yeah [ __ ]
custard
yay custard all right we had to start
putting this on tin cuz this is another
custard oh jeez
good lord this game is uh there's
something every we better check it out
yeah all right done hey check it out
okay checked great times
oh hi boy how you doing uh hey you ready
to find some cast as a boy I've shot I
am hungry I would love so hungry would
love some custards right now yay what
are we doing here can how did we end up
in this place
well I don't know how are those custards
here though that's a legend to me to you
again may be full of custard and me miss
panko okay no after you
whoa what's that your belly are you that
hungry
Hey yeah I am I'm gonna take this cousin
no no no oh boy promise me I get the
next one there okay I promise baby me
why did yeah okay yeah this is the kiss
the custard talking see Bailey hey I
hear somebody now my belly
it's matter and it's really angry it is
really only I shouldn't have like you
had that question I'm sorry I I turn
into another part oh god that is so
scary oh it's my belly again I guess oh
boy can't wait best cast it says my
belly will you shut up already shut up
stop moaning
makes me feel like a pedo pedo bear AB
you know Ted just a regular slender Toby
actually what the [ __ ] [ __ ] stuff
oh god I got one of those flashes while
I was using the camera so I didn't you
know I blocked it you blocked it [ __ ]
block FML sit I don't see any [ __ ]
custard and bean okay I need the kitchen
so your stomach shut up those that's
cool
uh I guess I'm not hungry anymore
where's this giant desert land what the
no custards to be seen they said the
custard was here they premises Castine
we'd been walking to stated for forty
years
Moses lead me to the custard
we split DNA you're hungry I can't hear
my belly that's how hungry I am
Oh God stop being such a [ __ ] belly God
shut up feed me Jesus well Oh is he here
no the frickin screens think they gave
me hey Jess you're such a [ __ ]
that's shut up you're obviously way too
scared
I'm over selling it I'm just trying to
be entertaining okay okay I see it I'm a
guy keep it it's in the temple oh my god
it's okay Ken I'll be some one of my
belly to shed it may be a trip hmm 13
you know one good Oh hate it
take it okay you're still hungry you're
gonna go so fat on camera I'm gonna
finish FDA's new dad's ten pound oh god
your face is gone it is don't worry
let's go yeah where's this month's
everyday don't know how many custer's do
we have to fight stop with the freaking
screams Jesus
oh Jesus that's what she's a monster
there's another custard and I'm taking
any [ __ ] I bet it's the developers
they're just like I bet no air oh man
play like let's make a spooky knife and
scared yet you right here are the Massa
bastard
well I don't think we're ever gonna see
it to be honest yeah I want to see it
yeah I want to see that see if it's
worth day it's supposed to be like all
skinny and weird-looking but okay okay
you see it no it's the stupid splashes
can't have you with at least your head
looks here - ten nine ten
thank you oh I see it no way I see it as
oh my god I started wait wait it's like
a weird wait wait we can't forget oh
yeah yeah Jenny that's a real question -
did you gotta be careful
oh yeah watch it very carefully it's
just it's like a Bigfoot it's the same
squids you're gonna be rich begin to be
faking witness okay I gotta give me the
case take Oh God
thank you stab him I guess there's a
cousin the Linnaean is true again
because I can't see it where do you go
Oh get the gas bag get the cash dear
whatever you do get - gasps - oh oh god
oh god I'm sis Kaede I'm just kidding
oh yeah okay okay okay you know camera
oh yeah yeah camera [ __ ] oh you can see
that Mitch everybody yes mattress where
I was Reagan was it I don't see him Ken
hey you're looking right at him why he's
right there well Oh God where did he go
by the case in my stick
this is break dancing like crazy did you
see this yeah it was sweet it even hit
you he was yeah I think it was just
touching me he's like oh you got the
custard mm-hmm
where'd you got the case in your
backpack it that giant ass of yours that
my free head neck acid we get I guess
you did all right
can't believe another concern you know
it lets out coasters now the master knit
oh good I got ya I got me Wow Wow
impressive cue the dubstep